hello and welcome back to bloodline the
taxonomy of fear where we discuss what
if anything makes the movie scary today
we'll be looking at disease horror in
the movie antiviral which stars caleb
landry jones from friday night lights in
it he plays a sales rep for a company
that sells viruses harvested from sick
celebrities yeah I don't really care how
famous or hot you are I don't want
George Clooney's hepatitis I know super
gross this character has a side business
where he steals some of the pathogens
from the company and sells them on the
black market what about Jennifer
Lawrence's hepatitis I mean if anybody
it would be her but no definitive no
zach galifianakis god no absolutely not
okay maybe zach galifianakis i think
we've got a personality profile on j
haha so far I've had all her diseases
must have been expensive strain you
ladies spread it ok so the criteria for
a disease horror movie how are we
defining this job alright number one you
need to define the parameters of the
disease yeah as the audience we need to
know what are the vectors what's the
infection rate what's the incubation
where the symptom what's the mortality
yeah we need to know either from the
very beginning or we learn with the
protagonist of the movie ok the problem
with this movie the the disease that he
has doesn't ever really go anywhere we
don't it's not defined and I I can't
started wondering well aside from
vomiting blood what else is involved in
this disease yeah it kind of was just
part of a very vague identity that
prevailed throughout the entire movie as
a disease of way too vague yeah and the
second criteria is race against time if
somebody being indeterminately sick or
just having a cough for a while that's
real life in a disease movie where
you're supposed to be horrified you need
to know that the clock is ticking when
that clock runs out you're dead and this
will be again with the vagueness kind of
had a very strange approach to time it
was a it was not really kept track of
you didn't really know how many days had
passed so was for me I thought it was
kind of satisfying because it was a
little disorienting like I didn't know
if it was day or night up or down but it
did kind of
give me a little curious as to when this
person's life was gonna run out you know
yeah finally number three cell the
sickness oh yeah I once had an acting
teacher telling me your job is not
necessarily to cry on stage or jobs to
make the audience cry and caleb landry
jones in his performance made me feel a
little bit sick he was a really good
he's a little weird looking to begin
with a little bit unhealthy looking but
yeah helped but he was excellent at
acting ill he put this movie on his back
and ran with it he was really fantastic
I loved the art direction and it was
really beautiful but where it did slack
Caleb Landry Jones just picked it right
back up again who did carry this movie
hours of sleep lost after watching
antiviral Jordan well disease movies are
my kryptonite so this one kept me up for
i'm going to say two hours afterwards
because there were some holes in it but
ultimately the vibe of it really carried
me through and Caleb Landry Jones again
just an outstanding performance I was
definitely a little jittery about what
would be ravaging through my body while
I slept that night I'm gonna say 10
minutes because I kept obsessing about
how far into the future is this and what
happened in the duration that made us go
from wanting to look like celebrities to
wanting to be infected by them and then
after 10 minutes of thing about that I
just fell asleep horror movie survival
lessons Jordan what did you learn number
one thou shalt not steal and yes it is
the eighth commandment which is not
generally a part of the horror movie
code but it was pretty much the only sin
that said March committed in this movie
that's true number two don't sell your
body not even parts of your body like
blood tissue muscle cells for that meat
now don't tell your buddies but number
three and this is huge beware of Malcolm
McDowell this guy is bad news it says on
his IMDB page that he often plays out
right villains he's like the British
judo cure if you see either one of those
guys walk into a room you walk out of
that room there are there are certain
red flags Udo Malcolm stellan skarsgard
they show up on screen you can pretty
much know the ending because they're
gonna be the villain they're gonna be
the bad guy even if real in real life
Malcolm McDowell moved in next door you
just might want to consider selling your
house or start a neighborhood watch
those are two missions
so we're business ok what is your
infectious video pic of the week Jay I'm
gonna pick blindness from 2008 about a
contagious form of blindness I like this
movie mostly because I couldn't finish
the book and I wanted to know what
happened is yeah well I couldn't finish
the book cuz it was so bad or it was so
claustrophobic and it's made me feel
anxious oh okay that's good news the
movie was a quick way to get through the
narrative yeah well i'm gonna go with a
movie from last year called the bay oh
my god is it's a late movie i mean i
like it's fairly defensible but I told
you it's diseased movies contagion
movies they just get me they ruined me
this is like a found-footage like small
creatures in a lake I don't even
remember where in the united states are
taking over a small town it's just it's
really bad but it really freaked me out
because the disease looks really gross
okay so that's a peek into your psyche
god I'm embarrassed alright so that's it
for this episode of bloodline email us
at bloodline at wired com we would love
to hear from you and as we like to say
your byline remember it's just a movie
go to the doctor anyway
you